yeah so hi everyone I'm Jeremy and today
I would like to talk about a project
called Jupiter light and this is going
to be a mix of Jupiter uh web assembly
and uh and python so
I'm currently working as a technical
director at constack and at constack we
do scientific Computing so we are
involved in the projects such as Jupiter
and also Mamba and the package
management
stories so
we maintain and contribute to many
Jupiter projects for example Jupiter lab
Jupiter widgets
Jupiter light and Via dashboard and the
many others so maybe maybe you can meet
us on GitHub as well
um
and this presentation presentation would
be about Jupiter light so you might
wonder like how is Jupiter light
different compared to normal Jupiter
so I have a couple of cells in a
notebook here and I can execute them
just like in normal normal GPU
so you might wonder like what's the
difference
so
I'm going to wait
um
so one of the main differences is that
with light it boots in a couple of
seconds so actually
here is the
the GitHub repo for this presentation so
this presentation is actually deployed
to GitHub pages and if you scroll down
you can actually hear
you know play with it at the same time
or later it will uh to be available
there and if you uh if you look at the
link here it's something on the
github.io and that means it's deployed
on guitar pages so
um so if I open this link it actually
gives me
Jupiter lab interface and just boot it
really quickly so that's one aspect of
Jupiter light
another thing is that there is actually
a CRI that's called a trip to write
package on a Pipi so if you go here we
actually publish a python package and
this python package is pretty much just
a static side generator so you can use
this CLI to just create your own static
website just like you would do with
something like jacket for example and
and in the end you get something like
you have all of the tools to create your
own jupyter website and you can create
your own in a couple of minutes so
there is a demo repo uh under the
Jupiter light org
and it's actually a template so if you
go here and you click on this button
uh I will create one just to just to
show you the flow so here I could say my
custom
Jupiter website
and um
and then create
what it's going to do is going to create
your own
repo from this template
and it's going to
deploy the drip Delight website on the
GitHub pages so one thing you might have
to check
is that we see in actions here you need
to be able to
write so but it depends on your default
on GitHub but normally this should they
should do it so it might take a couple
of minutes so
um
I might come back to that later but uh
you see here that there is actually a
build uh triggered and after the build
there is the deploy and wants to the
deploy is finished then you can access
your website uh just like this so in the
end you get
a lightweight Jupiter front end that
runs entirely in a browser so here we
didn't have to set up any server
there was no terminal no command line
involved no need to install python or
any other packages located was just a
variable right there in a browser
which means that it's very easy to
deploy so we have documentation uh to to
show you like all of the different
scenarios from the the ways you can
deploy uh Jupiter light on
a bunch of providers
um
so there's also another website you can
check is the the one for the the main
jupiterrite repo so this is where most
of the development is happening and this
one also has a some kind of nightly
build in some way that we push to um to
read the docs so if you visit this URL
you will also get a trip to Lite built
from from the tip of the main branch so
it's like a very uh very new things
available there
uh So guitar Pages gitlab Pages read the
docs but also other providers like Versa
or netlify that are usually like common
places to put static websites for like
front-end Developers
so yeah it's pretty uh it's pretty easy
to to deploy in the end because it's
just you know you just need a static
website a static server to serve static
files
so a little bit of History uh
so this ID of of having something like
that is fully static
like the Jupiter environment is not new
so jupiterrite is kind of a reboot of
many atoms of doing this so one of the
first ones was Jive by by Nick burveg
and Nick burback is now a contributor to
crypto Lite he's done a lot of things
for the project and and here we see that
there was a attempt of doing that with
uh something called Brighton so the run
for running python in a browser
then I started to experiment a little
bit with a minimal notebook UI based on
on the Jupiter lab ecosystem and
components so the idea was to build
something from from scratch from from
the bottom up and try to to make
something like a new application pretty
much so that gave this this thing called
P5 notebook really
specific to this JavaScript library
called p5.js
um but we also have other
projects and one of them is called
Bastion and Bastion is very similar to
Jupiter light but they they use
um the classic notebook uh so the you
know the jupyter notebook As We Know It
uh which is uh now uh duplicated but
um it's still worth mentioning because
they managed to to get based on in in
the schools so in France there is a
project
and it kind of gives students this kind
of environment online environment so
they can learn programming and a bunch
of things so that's really uh uh very
great
and um
one more project called the starboard so
it's not really Jupiter
but it's uh it's pretty nice so you can
mix different languages in the same
notebook is different approach but still
worth mentioning
and there is also observable which is
like very native to the browser it's
maybe a bit more focused for
JavaScript but it's also a different
Paradigm so it's more like reactive
programming with this kind of notebooks
it's still still interesting to
uh to keep that that in mind
so back to back to Jupiter light so with
light you get a Jupiter lab and the
Jupiter notebook interfaces so that
means
actually you might have noticed that
here we are in a in a notebook so this
is a kind of a sneak preview of the next
version of the classic notebook which is
going to be called notebook V7 and this
one is built entirely using crypto app
components and and works with uh Jupiter
light so
so this is uh one of the interfaces and
the other one is the one we also uh saw
briefly earlier uh so Jupiter lab
and and here you get pretty much
the usual things you would expect so
there are files you can go in different
folders you can open this notebook for
example and
um
and shows up here so you have your
running kernels there's also the table
of content on the side so just like
Jupiter lab in general
um but there is also
support for themes so you can switch to
another theme you can switch back to to
this just like in Jupiter lab and
also support for other display languages
so here we are going to change the
interface to to French
now I'm going to break back to Chinese
I'm kidding to English
so yeah so this is just using the whole
infrastructure that is already in place
for the lab and Jupiter light is really
just trying to make a good reuse of all
of this so we have like there is a
process which is crowdfunding for
translations and the jupiteri just
consumes this so just like Jupiter lab
so that's a very low effort to have
support for that as well so you can also
have code consoles
you can start the consult here to enter
some code
what do we have yeah and we have also a
support for the whole ecosystem of
extensions for Jupiter lab and
let's see maybe one that could be
interesting to to look at is the Jupiter
lab tour so this is kind of
it gives you a way to for example tell
your users what's what the UI is so it
kind of gives you a tour of different
things you have injected Labs so this is
an extension that is not part of Jupiter
lab but it was installed
next to this deployment so it's
available and there are just plenty of
other extensions that just work also
with jupiterrite just like in Jupiter
lab
foreign
just standing on the shoulders of giants
so it's really built uh like from the
ground up so we just kind of it's like a
Lego game can put all of the components
together and make this application and
the cool thing about Jupiter is that
it's actually it's more than just
interfaces
um it's uh there's like standards and
protocols so
the colors that you interact with in
this interface they kind of follow the
same protocol so it's just the same
which means that we can reuse a lot of
different things so like IPython also
works
[Music]
the other extensions and then we have
libraries like BQ plot and map.lib and
many others
Zeus which is a another ecosystem of
kernels built in C plus plus is also
compatible with this and then and then
we have piadite so I'm going to
right after
so we now are at the point where
we wonder what is web assembly so
usually we talk about Jupiter light as
as it was empowered Jupiter running in
the browser and here is here is the like
kind of the page you can find on the on
the Modzilla web docs about webassembly
so webassembly
is uh it's a new type of code that runs
modern web browsers
[Music]
performance
provides languages such as CC plus plus
C sharp rest
and I can compile so they can run them
on the web and it's also designed to run
alongside JavaScript
and all of this is very important
because
it just makes it possible to run a
python in a browser so Jupiter light
ships by default with a kernel is called
piolite and the pyrite is built on top
of biodite so there is biodide and
pyrolite is just adding the layer to do
all of the messaging that is a pretty
much the Jupiter protocol and also
adding support for IPython
and parody is Python and the scientific
stack compared to webassembly
so they took C python which is
mostly written in C and a bit of python
and added a couple of other packages
like numpy pandas simpi and many others
and just compiled all of this to
webassembly so it means that
here if I run this cells you get
uh python 3-10 so this is using the
latest stable paradite at the moment and
you get a bunch of
cool things like for example error
messages
so here you get this nice uh Arrow
printed here there's also basic support
for completions
um
the help
and also history so
the couple of magics not all Magic's
work but a couple of them do and then
there are a couple of other interesting
things that biodite exposes so
this line
says that we want to import fetch to the
fetch method on the browser from this
thing called JS and that means you can
actually make
HTTP request using the fetch method
from the browser and the inspect your
results using the Json viewer from
Jupiter lab so yeah so all the way but
that's quite quite useful because then
you can really see instead of having
just a bunch of text printed there you
can we can reuse a lot of things that
have already been done in this jupyter
ecosystem
so
that means for example Metro clip
works you can make plots also properly
so here broadly the ship a jupiterab
extension
[Music]
so that means we can also reuse it there
so here you get interactive graphs
running also in your browser
one thing that is worth mentioning is
to be able to use these extra packages
we need to install them first at runtime
using this thing called piplite and
piplite is a layer that jupiterrite adds
on top of something called micropip and
micropip is provided by biodite and it
lets you kind of download the python
packages from Pipi and install them
directly on the runtime so here we
install a there and then we can use
either right here you get the the charts
and you can also just like in normal
Jupiter
[Music]
yeah you can download them export them
and there are many other displays are
also supported like Joe Json this one is
pointing to
to us
and also
um
so that was about static graphs and
visualizations but there is also support
for widgets so maybe you've heard about
this thing called iPad widgets gives you
a set of controls like this you can
create sliders for example and then if
you look at the value update this and
then the value changes but then you can
do more fancy things like linking the
two so if you update this also Updates
this value here so this is just normal
iPad widgets and it also works for
crypto Lite because it also follows the
same same protocol
and there is also support for
other custom widgets and one of them is
a BQ plot BQ plot lets you create a
charts that look like this so you can
change the color change the field
markers
uh create a new one and then here you
can update um
kind of updates uh on the fly so
there is also IPI canvas iPad canvas is
a night by widget to use the HTML canvas
to draw things on the screen so here I'm
just just going to execute these cells
and this is creating a game of life
in uh
in this thing here so we're just going
to draw the first
uh first iteration and actually it's a
good um a good opportunity to
to Showcase another extension that was
made by the community it's called sticky
land and gives you this kind of sticky
sticky thing on the right so one thing
you could do for example is to drag and
drop here uh code apps the input and
then run another set after so you can
keep an eye on this thing running
while doing some of the things in your
notebook so you can even
uh make the same fruit so it's like a
window in a window but uh it could be
useful in some cases so here we can
close uh and we can close this as well
yeah so
so this was a demo of the Python kernel
uh using or like all of the libraries
are already available out there but I
also wanted to mention another thing
called Zeus so xus is a C plus plus
library for writing computer colors and
in fact there are actually already
many colors that are implemented with uh
with Zeus
uh one of them is called suskling
and suskling is C plus plus in The
Notebook
it's uh it works but not in Jupiter
light unfortunately not clear not yet
but a normal Jupiter it does and it's
quite quite uh remarkable but there is
another one
um yeah for python it's just an
alternative to the default iPad kernel
and a couple of others for Lua and SQL
and the fun thing was that actually
since if you remember whether somebody
it's like targets
uh languages like C C plus plus so C was
useful for C python but C plus plus now
is useful Focus so
so it meant it means that uh actually
you can compile episodes to webassembly
and that means bringing some candles to
the web uh so there's a blog post here
uh that you can check out if you want
more details and here I just wanted to
Showcase uh the one for SQL so it was
the color itself was created by by
Mayana and then a Torsen buyer took it
and pretty much compiled it to
webassembly so you get
a sequel also running in the browser
with a Jupiter interface
so let me see if I can do this first
yeah
and you can create a database
table insert data and then select the
data
insert mode data select
and then
what is interesting is that you can
actually use a USB Vega so secret
kernel has bindings for Vega so you can
do the same as we saw before you can
create charts from here on static charts
you can download them so it's just uh
just to Showcase that it's not on you
but python it's also but other languages
that can be compared to webassembly and
run on the web
and in fact there are a couple of
cameras already available for crypto
Lite
another ones that is interesting
especially in educational space is a Lua
and there is also the JavaScript kernel
P5 it's very similar to JavaScript
um rent is a bit more like of a toy uh
toy car loan and also the Eco chronology
which is more for testing
but yeah so more candles coming
um a quick word about working with files
so here we saw that in Jupiter lab we
have a bunch of files here so actually
those files they are coming from uh the
server so the HTTP server and they are
just static static files so
you can create more files if you want so
here you can create a magnum file uh you
can create a new a new notebook and they
will be
um
showing up here in the file file tree as
well but those will be saved in your
browser so here if I open a new browser
in incognito mode for example they won't
be visible but the others will be so
there is some kind of layering system
right now that lets you combine data
that you want to provide to your people
to your users from the start and also
let them create a new new files on
demand
uh there's one one caveat with this is
that it's not yet possible to access
these files from from a python notebook
so that's something that is still a bit
a work in progress well it is
technically possible so from python you
can access the index DB uh because
that's something that's supported with
the underlying tool called Ms Krypton
that takes the C Python and Compares it
to webassembly so biodite is using this
tool so with all of this you can
actually do it but it's not it's a bit
clunky so it's not as nice as doing uh
with open and then pacify them and work
with the file
but um should get there at some point uh
hopefully
so as an alternative there is also
another extension so this is a Jupiter
lab extension it's called the file
system access
and uh
another another issue with this
extension is that it's only compatible
in chromium based browsers so it's using
an experimental browser API that is not
standard yet but what happens
is that if you install it so it works
with crypto lab so you can also you
don't have to use it here with light you
can also work with lab alone so you have
a different file browser right here and
you can open
a folders so for example
there is this one maybe you know it's
called um
by juice
what what happens here is that the
browser will ask permission to read the
local file system so we say we say yes
and we can access
the local files from this interface so
we are using a static website hosted on
GitHub pages but we access local files
using this API and that means you can
open this
tsv file as a spreadsheet
but you can also open other notebooks
and work on them execute them
takes a while
yeah okay maybe I should have taken um
I made this one
come down yeah so this is
um this is useful because then you can
do work locally
um
without having to
upload them somewhere else because if
you use the normal fire browser you can
still upload files from here but they
will be uploaded through your browser
local storage so here it's just another
another alternative to uh to let you
work with files
let's see
yeah and speaking of fires so
one cool thing about the static
deployment is that you can just go to uh
here for example and let's say you want
to share this file and uh on this one
you can right click uh copy the
shareboard link and then you can send
that link to someone working with you
and then when they open uh
that link they get the two files open
automatically so that's quite quite
useful if you share the same the same
Jupiter light deployment
um and then we start talking about the
fun stuff so again
uh since Jupiter light is just reusing
as much as possible from all of the
other projects that we already talked
about one thing that landed in uh in
Jupiter lab recently is a real-time
collaboration so if you're interested
you should check out the the
presentation by Kevin Jans who worked
with us to get it get that into the core
crypto lab
and he has a
a talk which is available on YouTube
and that means that you can
also use it in Jupiter light so there's
uh however a difference so it's not
using the same kind of tech to
synchronize messages and send messages
across peers as in normal Jupiter lab it
is using something else called webrtc so
it's going to be peer-to-peer and it it
works but there are a couple of a couple
of issues so we can try that so I'm
going to
open uh this is Incognito now
this is Firefox
and I'm opening the same
the same notebook so here you see there
is a difference
compared to the the things we we saw
before is that there is this room
appended to the URL and if you change
the room then you can create some kind
of isolations between
users and it's also displayed right here
at the bottom and here I can actually
edit code and we see that
it's reflected on the other side and
when you execute the output is also
synced across peers so you get a kind of
serverless
real-time collaboration with the static
website so that's a
that's quite nice but again this is
really reusing a lot of the work that's
been done in uh in the Upstream projects
one of the cool thing with Jupiter light
is that there is
some support for offline mode
um so actually there are a lot of
configuration uh you can do you can do
uh it's all detailed in the docs you can
pre-download all of the Python packages
you need uh into a folder in archive you
can also download the whole biodite it's
going to be big it's a 150 Megs I think
if you take everything but then you can
put all of this together uh and put it
on USB stick and then you can work from
that
so in some some cases for example if you
are on the plane you can still work so
that's could be useful
and a quick word about how this works
under the hood
so
there is a server but not a real server
and it's a server that runs in a browser
so here on the on the left side we have
the trip to lab and the jupyter notebook
interfaces and on the right side we have
the the Jupiter server so it's very
simplified server but it does the job at
the handling the resources the kernels
the content out of this
and it's also using this framework
called lumino which is also used by
Jupiter lab and lumino has a plugin
system and that means that every kind of
components can be isolated in its own
plugin
so here we have a plugin for contents
kernels and the settings and also each
kernel is a
it's a plugin
so that gives a lot of flexibility so if
you want a deployment that only has one
color you can do it if you want to make
your own corner you can also develop it
as a Jupiter lab extension because this
is just reusing the same same system so
here again it's a lot of reuse from the
ecosystem
so with this we start to to think about
what what could be done uh more than
just offering notebook interfaces so we
we think that uh yeah Egypt right is
very useful in uh especially in the
educational space so
we just kind of a setup you don't have
to install python locally uh you don't
have to deal with terminal because very
often this is like the most complicated
part in learning python is just to be
able to install it although now it's a
lot of improvements uh has been done so
it's already much better than before but
still
and if you have for example workshops
and you want to teach something to
someone or you have like data science
courses you can just set up a quick
website with all of the content
um
another fun thing you can do with this
is uh for example making games and the
toston uh wrote to blog post about
Jupiter games so he took this thing
called box2d which is a C plus plus kind
of physics engine and then compiled it
to webassembly
and let me see maybe I can do a quick
demo
okay yeah or you can do it uh by
yourself so it's in uh in here
and here if you go to games
yeah you can play build beard
so you can run this
not sure if it's going to take some time
too good
watch out so it'd be hard
um
this is a word of Goo uh this is also
rocket a game where you land a rocket so
the whole idea is to kind of especially
for kids who want to learn python or run
programming if they have some
uh environments like this
okay maybe it's a
game maybe I picked the wrong one but
yeah if they have some environment like
this it's much easier for them just to
get into the the fun part uh from the
start so that's uh that's kind of the of
the goal uh with this project and um
uh one thing that also happened uh with
all of this in place is that uh there is
Jupiter lab there is a triple notebook
but what if you could have something
even simpler like even more minimal so
there is now this thing called the
wrapper which is shipped by default in
Jupiter light
and you can embed it in your website so
if you take this code iPhone code and
just put it in your in your blog for
example with Jackie blog you can get a
python console uh available
made available to your visitors so just
for the sake of it I did this for my
website uh just just to test if that
works nicely or not and you get this
conquers over here so you can run
run some code
so we still are using the same kind of
components as we saw before so this is
just a Jupiter lab console that has been
put into its own application so yeah
here's taking a little while
um still downloading uh the biodite
assets but once loaded then it should be
pretty fast so
there you go python
easy to embed python report and that
kind of when people start to see this
they want it to have the same on their
website so we had a numpy numpy maybe I
can load this it's already preloaded
numpy.org so if you go there and you
scroll down a little bit there is also
[Music]
um
this report that you can
you can use to test numpy so this is
really really nice because then people
who just want to to play with it uh
check the API can just copy paste the
code on the print there and you get a
numpy in a browser
um
on the jupyter website there is this
page called try and
there are a lot of examples to try a lot
of things using the jupyter interface
and most of them are backed by a project
called binder so it pins the server for
you but you can do a lot of things with
it but the problem is that recently the
binder project they they run into some
issues with the with the funding so this
is where uh Jupiter light was useful
because when we want to demo the jupyter
interfaces we don't need to have a
full-blown server and instead we can use
the egyptolite
uh
project so that here if you want to try
crypto lab you can just click on that
and it gives you actually your Jupiter
Knight so it's not exactly the
full-blown Jupiter but it's enough
because uh the most important thing in
that case is to just give you an
overview of what you can do with such
tools
um so yeah it had had a huge impact on
on the on the cost so they managed to
cut down by I don't know maybe 30 or so
so here we were just trading
um
yeah compute resources for static assets
so it's just a bit more bandwidth but
less compute
and another one so simple I also joined
uh joined the party uh recently and
actually it's
um
just merged it was just merged yesterday
so it's very new and if you go to the
Senpai website it's actually if you go
here and you click on online share
uh you also get this little report here
so you can try some Senpai directly in
your browser without having to install
anything and they provide a bunch of
example code here so we can you can put
it
in the
in the report
and the interesting thing here is that
uh
with the jupyter interface all of this
is rendering really nicely because it's
using math checks to render render the
map so hopefully
yeah this will yeah this will finish so
you get some kind of output like this so
that's quite um quite useful
yeah and then if you want to do that on
your own documentation you can use a
project called crypto Lite things for
example iPad canvas is using that uh
they embed a notebook
notebook so you can play around with a
with a library
more to come pandas is also going to to
do the same as in numpy the thing is you
can even think about doing that for many
other languages because Jupiter is a
network agnostic so that just like we
saw with SQL you could also have reports
for for SQL
so yeah that's maybe we'll see that
happening soon so of course there are a
couple of limitations so this is more
suited for later workloads so it's good
for education for example
if you want to install packages you need
to install them with micro people
piplite for now at least there is
ongoing work to
improve that part
accessing files from python kernel is
still a bit clunky as we discussed
before the initial download can be a bit
big it's like maybe 13 Megs but then the
browser should already help a little bit
by caching a lot of these static assets
and uh for Paradise so like running
python in the browser there are also
other limitations like there is no real
threading so process it's possible but
in theory but is probably going to need
some work so sockets is also problematic
and not everything is implemented by
webassembly so if you are interested in
the the future of the python in the web
browser so there is a keynote by
Christian jaimez a core python developer
at the pycon D and Pi data burning
conference that was last month and it
should be available on YouTube soon they
started from this repo and a couple of
folks they kind of worked in this report
and then Upstream all of the patches to
C python the like the core c python repo
so now the C python like the tip of the
the main branch compares to webassembly
which is just great because then we
don't need to have patches in parody
anymore
uh the pilot folks they also did a talk
at pycon us so you have the slides there
if you want to check them and there is
also uh ongoing work on the whole
package management story and the idea
here is to try to reuse a lot from conda
so if you have already used conda it's
very easy to install packages that are
not Python and for that there is
topstone and wolf who are working on
something like this that will be also
compatible with Jupiter light
and there is also some activity
happening in the in the python discourse
about webassembly so there's a new
category that was created last week to
talk about
C python Paradise Jupiter light is also
this new thing that was uh announced
last week or two weeks ago at pycon us
called the pi script which is also using
biodite
so yeah up next for crypto Lite a lot of
things so this content management a lot
of improvements to do there uh
there is also like this new uh versions
of Jupiter drive a notebook coming up
and tryptite is just able to reuse all
of this uh almost out of the box so we
would just update that through the new
packages and benefit from all of the
improvements
and then there are improvements that can
be done also to cut completion so the
idea could be to run LSP server in a
browser to have better completions and
finally maybe have also some support for
voira so what that gives you like this
kind of dashboarding system to take your
notebook and transform it into a
dashboard and it will be cool if this
could be also run in a browser
automatically so
with this uh just uh wanted to say thank
you to all of you and also to all of the
contributors
thank you Jeremy and we have some
questions
so the first one is about the
performance
does it support vectorization in numpy
for instance
uh I think so but I'm not sure you won't
get the same same performance as a
as if you will be running it in on your
machine so I think there is still a
performance uh penalty uh and
vectorization I think
uh I think it's in the works I'm not
sure it's available yet we need to
double check yeah
another I have to be close so another
question is about compiling extensions
in C C plus plus site so the docs
describe how to compile those extensions
are there any limitations or how it
works
yeah so I mean a good place to start
would be the the paradise repo
um so they have a bunch of recipe
recipes to compile
[Music]
packages that are sea extensions and
they are available here
so some things will not work as we saw
like threading for example material
processing or a bunch of things are not
supported by the app script and platform
um so I think the best shot would be to
try and see if you can
um if you can
uh making compiler or not and uh yeah I
think the the only the only um way to
add such packages to uh to be able to
use them on the web for now at least is
to follow the the paradise approach and
use their build system at least until we
have this new
M script and Forge
infrastructure in place that will be
able to reuse more things from conda
thank you so another question is about
integration with Git or GitHub so how do
you connect changes from Jupiter to git
yeah so git doesn't run in a browser so
unfortunately the git extension for
crypto lab doesn't work uh with Jupiter
light so but there are some some options
there so for example vs code.dev and
github.dev they also have support for uh
working with GitHub at least so one
thing that could be interesting to look
into we haven't haven't checked that yet
but would be to use uh another way of
working with uh with gitso like running
in a browser for example in JavaScript
and then and then use the GitHub API for
example to commit changes just like they
do in github.data
thank you another question is related to
the packaging story is it possible to
easily at your own body package
yeah is it if it's a pure python package
you can just install it on the Fly With
micropip or piplite like we saw here
with all of the widgets and other
libraries if it's a more complicated
package then the best shot for now is to
use this
uh tuning that is in place again it's
the same kind of the same as what we
discussed before until we have this uh
conda infrastructure in place here the
detail about how to create a pipeline
package so yeah so that will mean
creating
another kind of paradise distribution
and then uploading it yourself to your
web server and then using that from
Jupiter light which is all possible but
it's a bit more effort
thank you and we have lost two questions
one of them is
do you think that one day you'll be able
to run a contra Fort package in browser
including those depending on C plus
piece like gdal
maybe either that I don't know but one
interesting thing is uh maybe a
think
I don't have it here
[Music]
now
our
never mind
um worth who's working with what
constack just published something on
Twitter today I need to find it so he
was able to run a member so micro member
in a browser
so that means like in Mumbai if you
don't know it's uh it's like uh it's
like Honda but faster so
you can install packages uh using a
mobile as well and he was able to
compile a micro number to webassembly
which means that you can run Mamba and
the Mumbai solver which is using lipsor
directly in the browser so maybe at some
point we'll be able to have some I mean
like running Honda directly here and
install packages like this and make them
persist in some way but this is all
still you know very Cutting Edge so a
lot of unknowns
thank you and the last one is the
comparison between jupiterolite and
standard Jupiter what are the
significant drawbacks
yeah I think the drop axis mostly the
the limitations we have here
so you know it's running running in a
web browser it's not as powerful as if
you had your own server
um but it's always a game of of
trade-offs in the end so it depends on
what you want to do if you want the
full-blown Jupiter and you know how to
to um
to make it run on your machine
then you can just do it as normal you
might not get this but if you want
something for like newcomers who haven't
done any programming before
then you can use some some something
like this like a like Jupiter but yeah
the the main differences would be more
about the limitations that we've seen
here
yeah
okay thank you Jeremy so please what's
thank you
[Applause]